could not be more thrilled to have my
next guest
uh join us right here and couldn't be we
could all use some good news
in 2020 and here's some good news the
15th studio album of this man's stellar
legendary career is being released
and it is called 2020 he is none other
than the great
john bon jovi how are you sir hi
guys very well thank you happy to call
in
happy to have you here he's a first time
caller long time there you go there you
have it
john john from so what would i say
you're john from sayerville what would i
say
yeah it's terrible ceremony the other
side of the outer bridge yep
right over the driscoll bridge then you
know you call the outer bridge to the
driscoll the big bridge on the other
side
yep right right there on the parkway
is where i used to play football
literally they'd say go play in traffic
that's where we would play
is that right so what did you what
position were you
when you were doing this oh and pop
warner that's you know that junior high
stuff no i'm talking like when we go out
and throw the ball around with your
friends
okay there was a grass field and i'm
talking about you know the early
to mid 70s you'd play football on the
parkway
and my parents they had a death wish for
me they're like go play in traffic
now when you say the parkway you're
talking about like an act
the actual garden state park
oh my god john come on because you you
look you say you know the outer bridge
you cross the outer bridge and then
there's the driscoll
and you're going south it's right there
the foot of that bridge
there there wasn't an exit at the time
what is now an exit
yep used to be a grass field right
across the street from that
exit was literally my street
robin hood drive in sierra leone
and we used to ride our bikes and that's
where we would play football
now what we're going down memory lane
being from staten island i would go
across the outer bridge on occasion
and go to the met the uh monster
multi-cinema
metroplex that was there exactly that
was the foot of the bridge
that's exactly right that's where we
would go because you know if the times
in staten island weren't
good we'd just go across and we'd go to
new jersey to see a movie so when you
when you were playing on the garden
state parkway words i never thought i
would set up a question for jon bon jovi
in my life but
uh who did you imagine you were being
who was you who were you emulating
in those football games shirley giants
fran parkington
uh fred dreyer frederick
you know i mean like the early 70s
giants
that was your those were so you weren't
i guess i guess that's northern
enough for you not to be philly correct
yes television feed
like yours because people ask me that as
the years went why did you own
an arena team in philly and blah blah
blah yes we were we were new york
based uh new jersey yes so are you still
i guess what's your team now john
uh if you've got to clean the patriots
for some 25 years right because uh
my relationships to bill and to mr craft
and you know
tom and everybody up there so i've been
friends with them for
well since parcells was head coach so
wherever they went i went
and uh and then you know as i got
friendlier with mr craft and we became
tight
i was always a patriots guy since
bledsoe
so you know it's interesting john uh i i
um
got to spend a couple days with bill
belichick when he was the
analyst on the nfl 100 all-time team
program
at nfl films and i i got to see
what everybody who's gotten to know
belichick
in person of who he is and sense of
humor
and everything that you don't see when
he's
moving on to cincinnati and stuff like
that at the podium
what's your uh take on bill and you got
a good story about music
or anything there's a lot of good
stories um you know because
like i said he and i i do you remember a
punter on the giants by the name of sean
lambert
of course okay sean's a good old friend
of mine
and he'll always be a dear old friend of
mine because i met him one night in the
china club
in new york city this is like 89
and and he had his super bowl ring on
and he knew i was a big giants guy
and uh and he let me try the ring on and
then
he says you know if you really want
maybe i could ask parcells if you could
come to practice and if you remember
back in those days
practices were never open to the public
sure and
george young was the gm oh yeah you know
mr mara mr wellington now
the duke was yeah the duke was alive and
they would be at practice so one day
parcells allowed me to come to practice
and the first thing he did was yell at
me and i said oh i know you you're my
pop warner coach
i wasn't even intimidated by that but as
our relationships built
you know then and i got more active if
you will i became sort of the mascot
and so that young guy belichick
charlie white we became pals like
really pals you know partels was still
dad and he was the boss and
he was incredibly kind to me to let me
in the locker room on the bench
you know traveling with with the to the
team to away games
but my friendships built with belichick
and
white and uh and and wherever
they all went i would go and visit and
hang out
blah blah blah right and then you know
come 96
at that super bowl against green bay i
met mr craft for the first time
and then of course i'd go to practice
every year
and uh i opened gillette stadium
uh much like i opened met life stadium
so my nfl connections were going and
going and gone
so then belichick would come on the road
with us but we never
told people those stories you know he's
a closet drummer um
you know so like there's like all kinds
of stories about bill that
the world doesn't know because he's so
focused on work when he's working sure
but when he's not working you know he's
a a wonderful warm
sweet guy believe it or not and of
course he's a genius
but all that aside you know the
personality of the dad
that i know the guy that likes a rock
and roll band that i know
you know that i've had more than one
drink with in my life i know
you know so that's the different guy i
know and i'm i'm allowed that access
because i never take advantage of
it's kind of like fight club and as a
matter of fact i'm a little concerned
even bringing it up right now but uh
there's a couple of threads i do want to
pull
uh a little bit here so um you said on
the road
so he was a uh a john bon jovi roadie
for a little bit i wouldn't pay the road
he's flying on the plane with me but
[Laughter]
no bill you know bill's coming out oh
yeah he's been out on the road with us
uh you know in that little brief window
before
camp would start if he got those couple
weeks off he came
over to europe one year he's been to
shows in the states
oh absolutely i um for a hundred years
now
yeah and then when you say closet
drummer like
he likes music and he's banging on a
drum kit you know yes
yes so what does his channel years ago
what are his chops i mean when you
can he can he oh he probably plays drums
as well as i play football but doesn't
mean
you know it's interesting but he gets to
make a living
you know but it doesn't mean you can't
bang on exactly it's
odd enough we're looking it up he wants
bang the drums in the middle of the
garden state parkway it's very strange
uh you have the same roots john it's
kind of crazy
jon bon jovi here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about your album 2020 what a
year man
um and and and we all need
stuff like this from you i'm wondering
if you needed to make it
john um you know it's funny when in 2019
it was march of 19
we went to nashville to make the album
what i thought was the album was really
just the first batch of
songs because even though i had the
album title in mind
it was a dual meme clear vision because
i sort of
had been through a tumultuous time but
really felt i had clear vision again
compounded by the fact that i laughed
and said election year
sure will sell a lot of t-shirts but as
events unfolded
i started to write more and more topical
songs
and address a lot of what was going on
and i said okay
if i can just bear witness to history
don't take sides just report the facts
and i really set out to do that and i
think we accomplished it
once covet came and i had to delay the
release of the record
outright canceled the tour uh i had an
opportunity to write a couple more songs
one of which is the
current single which happens to even be
number 10 on the charts
about covert for lord's sake and it's
called if you can't do what you do
you do what you can't and that was one
and then in light of what happened with
the death of george floyd i was really
taken by it and i wrote a song called
american reckoning
that's when i said okay i'm witness to
history this album titled a lot deeper
than i thought
and and we release it you know this week
and then um you know obviously 2020 has
been just a rough year for so many
people
john and um you know and and
it just seems one negative uh
development after another
it just keeps hitting you uh and then
this past week the passing of eddie van
halen i know you've spoken of it
uh and spoken about it i'd love to give
you the floor
about eddie to my audience and your
recollections of the passing of eddie
van halen from a couple days ago
you know to be in the company of true
greatness a legend and a genius because
he
like the the true creators of the
electric guitar whether it was les
paul himself or jimmy page or eric
clapton eddie van halen's name is
mentioned in the same way
and when i came up in the late 70s and
you know he was at
what six seven years seven years older
than i am
they got signed in like 78
every teenage kid who ever looked at an
electric guitar dreamed
of you know playing it like eddie van
gaal and nobody could
but you emulated it and there was a lot
of people who copied it but there was
only
truly one original and that was the
legacy of eddie van halen
he made his mark and and he'll always be
remembered for him
jon bon jovi couple more minutes left
with the the rock and roll
and uh musician and legendary jon bon
jovi here
on the rich eisen show tell me about
your foundation what's going on with the
jb's
j seoul foundation let's do some good
here in 2012 oh my goodness
lots uh you know we have
been in the in the foundation business
for some 15 years now once upon a time i
found it under the guise of sports
ownership
because once upon a time i used to want
an arena football team and i thought
the only way that we're going to
ingratiate ourselves in philadelphia
was to be at least as or more
philanthropic than the big four
and so when the foundation found focus
uh it was in the food insecurity and
housing the homeless
and since then we've built nearly a
thousand units of affordable housing
coast to coast
i have three community restaurants where
i was working when i came up with the
title for do what you can
because i was washing business which is
typically a volunteer positions
for people who are in need they come and
they they work in the restaurants and
they they're empowered
when they come and they volunteer and
then in
in light of what was happening in 2020
with the dire need for food out on
eastern long island we opened a food
bank and provided the food to seven
pantries for the last
four months so the spike in the need for
food
has been off the charts in our in our
simple adages
we don't need a scientist to find the
cure it was going to take money and
sweat equity
and so we had a little of both and we
opened these restaurants in the food
bank and
built these houses and the continuation
of the foundation happens every day
jbjsf.org so that's for the jbj
soul foundation jbjsf.org to find out
more
and participate in it um john i
really appreciate you calling and it's
just a blast always is um
my wife who's such a huge fan of yours
just wanted me to
send her i send you uh her best my my
nephew jack goes to syracuse he texts me
he's like ask him how his son likes
syracuse
he loves it yeah yeah yeah so it's great
and um
i appreciate the time always uh here on
the program
thank you it's so great to call in i
look forward to it you guys
appreciate it brother have a great day
you take care john you take care you got
it that's jon bon jovi
john bon jovi twitter and instagram